In one of the cases, the six
conservative justices decided that the state
of Arizona can maintain two laws that
impact voting access. The first
law allows the state to get rid of
votes cast in allegedly wrong ones.
The second prohibits third parties from
delivering the ballots of other parties.  people
including family members or people
who do not previously have transportation
the
federal appeals court in san francisco decided that the
arizona laws were illegal because they
disproportionately
impact hispanic blacks and native
americans but the
conservative justices of the supreme court -
decided  that arizona can uphold
those laws by saying the state has
the right to protect the integrity of
its elections democrats say
this decision will encourage other states to
pass more restrictions and limitations
on voting access in the last decision
of the term the supreme court ruled
which is not constituted  national, a
california law that requires charitable
organizations to disclose the names of
their largest donors, but some
quality-qualified organizations are involved in
politics and even raise funds for
certain causes or political candidates, which is
why some groups  and
political experts say they are concerned that
this supreme court decision may
result in less honesty in the
political arena reporting in washington
alexandra limón